trevor bauer and the dodgers looking for
a fourth consecutive win and a fifth out
of their last six according to
statcast's run values his fastball is
the number one individual pitch in
baseball not just saying his fastball is
the best fastball but you put every
pitch that every pitcher throws his
heater's been the most valuable one
rojas climbs in on a 3-2
swings and misses as bauer turns the
fastball up a few miles per hour to
finish him off bauer starts his night
with a punch-out strikeout number one
for trevor one down jesus aguilar will
be the baddie and another strikeout
sharp slider two goal
two batters two strikeouts for bauer
that's a good hitter that he made look
silly two down here's dickerson
dickerson who is very hard to strike out
comes back and gets a generous inside
corner according to chad fairchild
trevor bauer strikes out the side to
start the ball again the 24 year old
from arvada colorado jordan holloway who
got caught up earlier this season
because of the injury issues they're
dealing with in the rotation
started his time with five shutout
relief appearances and they made his
first start monday against arizona
in the air to right field
drifting back now is
garrett cooper to make the play corey
seger and a couple hits as part of that
nine run output yesterday a check swing
and seeger did not go so he'll go down
to first base instead that's ball four
one on and one out for justin turner
seven straight misses from holloway
back-to-back rocks
the table set for one of the hottest
hitters in the league and max muncie
last eight games muncie is 10 for 28
with five home runs and 11 runs batted
swinging to miss great pitch got him to
chase one below the zone two away that's
the first strike after holloway and a
big second out in the first now to be
after will smith bouncing ball up the
middle near the back at second base diaz
has it over to first for the out that
ends the inning and it wasn't easy but
holloway hangs a zero in the first
pitching around a pair of free passes
trevor bowers struck out the side in the
first inning he's back out there in a
scoreless second
fastball gets him looking and he's
retired the first four on the strikeouts
one out and sandee has the battery
comebacker to get him and he struck out
the first five
how about this five strikeouts to start
the game for trevor bauer and three of
them looking the last three in a row he
has got the marlins looking i mean
basically for the first five hitters
bauer's been playing catch with will
smith
off the end of the bat to first they put
it in play but at six up six down for
trevor bowell with five strikeouts
jordan holloway back to work here in the
bottom of the second this is gavin lux
the lefty hitting second baseman
swinging and miss you got him to chase
the curve ball down and away and after
those back-to-back one-out walks in the
first holloway now is retired five
straight with a couple of k's trevor
bauer has faced six batters he struck
out five of them and now he'll face the
bottom part of the order starting with
the switch hitting catcher sandy leone
got him with the elevated fastball
already his sixth k as he's retired the
first seven the pitcher holloway is
bowers retired the first eight that only
makes sense jordan holloway would get
the first hit tonight that's the first
major league hit for jordan holloway
that's off a brand name right there
marlins have their first base runner in
this third inning going getting miguel
rojas up there he chases one that's in
the dirt kicks all the way over to the
first base dugout
miggy is going to reach on a strikeout
in a wild pitch so aguilar who just
couple minutes ago is making himself
heard arguing straight calls over in
that first base dugout comes up with
runners at first and second and two gone
tap past the mound is short seeger's
there
that's the end
a couple of base runners but no damage
done trevor flower with seven strikeouts
over three onions cory dickerson will
lead things off he strikes him out with
a fast ball already his eighth strikeout
of the game and just one gone in the
fourth and the ninth strikeout of the
game for bauer barry just looks like the
man on a mission there goes the runner
on a payoff pitch that swung on and miss
bauer with a strut off the mound has
equaled his season high for the third
time this season he has struck out 10
men in a game
turner and muncie was single smith with
a walk and the bases are full of dodgers
chris taylor coming up 3-1 taylor
watches the dodgers have the game's
first run
turner will step on home bases loaded
walk for chris taylor one nothing and
here's baby fest wall gets him looking
that baby's been thrown out of the game
boy you talking about a quick hook
i don't know what matt could say in
three words that's one of the quickest
hooks
here's gavin lux with the bases loaded
one out bouncing ball is
[Music]
[Applause]
at first i thought the ball came out of
his glove then he goes into a throwing
motion i'm like that's his shoe
you actually didn't say that you
literally took your shoe off to make
sure i knew what happened
corey seeger with the lead off man on in
front of him seeger tried to get out of
the way it looked like it might have hit
him on the hand this is dangerous when
you have your hand hit and you're
holding a bat
and dave roberts comes sprinting out
because he understands that seeger's in
some discomfort we're going to take him
out of the game if nothing else to get
some treatment get an evaluation
immediately max muncie the battery is
[Applause]
this will load the bases and taylor who
came up in this same situation last
inning and drew a walk to bring in the
first run of the game gets that ball off
him simber sprints over to get it and
feeds aguilar for out number two but
noises in the score and it's four
nothing
trevor bauer back out to work through
six he's working on a two hit no walk
shutout with ten strikeouts
swatted to right mookie betts is there
seven shutout innings from
trevor bauer the bases are loaded it'll
be dj peters batting in the nine spot
here for the pitcher
[Applause]
for peters it'll drive home too you
don't blame him for getting a little
extra excited as he drives home too
first big league rbis for dj peters
and it takes a four nothing lead and
makes it a much more comfortable six
nothing mookie bets at the plate
to center field sierra angles over to
catch it but it'll bring home lux
touchdown and an extra point to nothing
seven nothing dodgers joe kelly's second
outing of the season comes here in a
seven nothing game in the ninth inning
spun along first easy play muncie good
stuff joe kelly with a one two three
nine
and good stuff for the dodgers overall
tonight a 7-0 win they're fourth in a
row
[Music]